foreign
myths four lies
that people say and some people believe
about wealthy people
number one they're brilliant
they have an inordinate amount of brain
power
in other words their gpas are all 4.2
not true
not true we already heard that this hour
2.7 in there yeah we got a two under
three and one 4.0 uh the typical
millionaire the typical person we talked
to that is wealthy
has around a 3.0 GPA
if they remember it
is that like just straight average is
that kind of a beat right at the you
know three three point two something
like that right in there is what we find
uh uh we didn't actually study that in
the Ramsey millionaire study that's just
from us hanging out with millionaires
for many years now uh I find over and
over and over again you really can't be
dumb
I mean like I have a 1.0 GPA like you
played beer pong the whole time or
something you can't be dumb and
typically build wealth you generally
have to have some level of intellect
some ability critical thinking skills
ability to stick with something ability
to think through something but um but it
does not require that you're a genius
which means I have a chance
so you're saying there's a chance right
Dumb and Dumber quotes so there you go
but um yeah I'm saying there's a chance
I'm saying there's a chance um there is
very uh sadly they're they're while
they're while intellect a level of
intellect is there the other thing we
find is not a necessary level of
education completed uh although we find
a large number have college degrees uh
but the um what we do find is they're
almost all lifetime Learners like our
last one Donna 66 years old with nine
million dollars she continued to go back
and get degrees because she started in a
dead-end job making nothing looking
around at 55 year old broke women going
I'm going to be one of them I don't want
to be one of them so what'd she do she
just kept learning and even when she got
a divorce what'd she do she went and
bought a condemned house I don't know
how to fix it up but I think I can
figure it out figure it out continual
learner continual learner continue a
learner always reading always growing
always learning always putting something
new in their cap how many books have you
read since the first of the year I've
completed three non-fiction books this
month I'm on a roll I'm on a roll I
don't actually do that many a month but
I'm on a roll right now and I've got uh
I've got a great non-fiction Jack Carr's
new ones laying on there a great fiction
book I'm sorry it's a great one and then
I've got a non-fiction laying on my desk
right now and I'm getting ready to start
too and um I'm just going to tear into
them just I find everything I want in a
book reading reading reading reading
reading reading so I see that a lot with
millionaires they you know yes I admit
it I watched Tiger King but I also read
okay and so I have to offset my brain
the real admission that I killed
watching Tiger King have to be
replenished by reading so that's it so
yeah I mean we all do we all do some
things we regret it was 20 20. it was a
tough year it was a hard year it was a
very hard year for for a lot of tigers
and so um well my favorite stat in there
was that 97 of the millionaires believe
they control their Destiny I want that
is profound because most 69 of the
public does yeah so comparatively to the
general public there's a high
correlation of I believe I can do it
yeah if you think you can you think you
can't you're right and here's one of the
ones that I think is so classic it fits
with this
envy and jealousy culture that we're
building which is kind of a a core tenet
of socialism right you know I have to
Envy someone I have to hate someone's
success I have to be jealous of
someone's success and this one Falls in
that bucket all wealthy people are
Crooks because that's known way to
become wealthy you have to be crooked
and the weird thing is I've met
10 I've met thousands and thousands of
millionaires 30 years doing this and I
have met hmm
over 50 in person had conversations with
them billionaires and that's a thousand
million and out of those billionaires I
only know
two of them
that I can remember that are complete
butts
they were complete and if I named them
you would know them I mean they're that
they're that kind of butt and they're
like famous butts you know that's one of
the best kind yeah and so uh but the the
rest of them are some of the nicest
people on the planet because here here's
this is fat this is a truth broken logic
okay the logic of this says you rip
people off to get money
the problem with that is
that when you rip someone off
word gets around
and the next one is harder to rip off
and then word gets around and the next
one's even harder to rip off so you're
running a business let's just call it a
car repair place and you
don't repair someone's car and you
overcharge them you rip them off
so if that's you and you get ripped off
by the car repair guy what do you do
you tell your friends stay away from put
it on Facebook yeah don't go there stay
away from this guy he's a crook right
leave a bad review yeah and and pretty
soon the guy's out of business he's not
wealthy but if the guy takes really good
care of you going he goes hey that he
spends about five minutes fixing your
car and goes oh it's just one little
thing here he turns the screw and what I
owe you buddy nothing just remember me
when you have a real car repair and tell
your friends
well guess what you do you remember him
when you have a real car repair and you
tell your friends and you look up 10
years later and the guy's got shops in
five cities
and he's worth about 10 million dollars
because all he did was honestly repair
someone's car a lot
that's all he did
and he's got a net worth of five or ten
million dollars they're all over the
place so it turns out the best way to
become wealthy's high integrity is what
the actual critical thinking leads us to
believe versus ripping people off so
this idea that all the rich people are
Crooks all that means is you're a
small-minded jealous person who doesn't
know how life works that doesn't say
anything about rich people I mean it
says something about you what makes it
the logic doesn't make sense because if
they get wealthy that automatically
makes them a crook based on their own
logic well that means you wouldn't want
to get wealthy that's the person that's
saying that I wouldn't want to be rich
because all those rich people are bad
people and it's quite the opposite most
of them are really good people who've
helped a lot of people that's how they
become wealthy you know and I've noticed
this about us no one was pissed off when
I sold ten dollar books helping people
get out of debt out of the trunk of my
car and I helped 10 people and I sold 10
books making ten dollars nobody was mad
but now that I've sold 20 million of
them Dave Ramsey got rich on the backs
of poor people
no I helped more people than I did when
I was doing another trunk of my car a
lot more people got help now and they
gave you certificates but now because of
scale I'm automatically Evil all that
means is you're an idiot if you say
stuff like that that's all that means
and that's not me being defensive it's
just your critical thinking skills suck
when you do that I mean you're just
exposing yourself it's just bad